Gaaaah!
Lawnmower of- oooh, I get it.
Gurraaaaaaaah!
Oh, I'm okay.
I thought I wasn't going to make that one.
Oh boy, now I get to go on a nice little rampage.
Oh no! Oh this is bad.
Oh, it so horrible! Stop! No!
Hayoop-ding.
'Scuse me!
I need to get into the secret lab...
... that you guys are talking about.
Pardon me, sir.
Don't shoot, I'm too beautiful to die.
Uh-oh.
AAAARGH!
96.25% perc-HEUGHHOUHOU
Let me live and I'll give you my booooody.
Nyeh. WOOOH!
That didn't help at all.
You guys believe in me, right?
Hhhhhhey, I'm still alive!
Aaaah, come on!
Maybe if I'm sassy about it-gaaah!
Everybody concentrate! I need your focus here!
Heugh!
AAAH!
Up my butt.
Did you really focus it up my butt?
AAAAH!
Everybody...
...help me!
It hurts...
...my balls.
Aaand I'm dead.
There's nothing wrong with dancing...
...with your own leg, man.
You do what you do!
You get freaky with yourself!
Quite literally in fact!
You found me?
I'll kill you!
AAH!
I'll smash this table onto your balls!
...or onto mine...WAIT...NO! THISISWRONG!
Ugh!
I ain't afraid of you!
'Cause I killed myself.
That's why.
That's all you get.
Thank you!
Eughugh.
ECH.
HEEEEEEEY! That counts!
It counts! It got me a win!
Iiiii think that I will not have a problem with this.
You didn't tell me there was anything else!
As I was saying...
...I'm bad.
COME ON!
LITTLE MORE!
Now-DEUAGH.
Dallright you kiddies.
Wait a minute... kiddies... wait-w...
You're not my kiddies.
This isn't my sleigh!
W-what happened last night?!
Did Santa drink too much egg-nog?
Oooh. Ookaay.
RuUun from my sloOow caAar!
You better hope that...
...you don't stay there for a bit...
...because this is gonna get...
...very dangerous...
...very quickly.
You watch out as well!
It is very dangerous.
Stop humping each other...
...and get scared.
'Cause this is gonna get craaazy!
[BURP]
This obviously a...
...a Porsche 911 Turbo.
I've been watching my Top Gear.
This is a Porsche 911 Turbo.
...(Harp)oon-run!
WEEEE!
Ow.
NOO!
Oh. :(
Come on!
Something besides just instant death...
...would be delightful.
Maybe if I'm happy and positive about it...
...I can make it.
Well, those are up my butt...
...but that's okay.
Fly fl--
AAAWGH.
[winning noises]
Wrecking balls!
For the first time in my life...
...I can't handle this many balls!
HAARHG!
I didn't make it.
Doopty.
Oh no--AUGH ECH
NOO!
Come on, get the last target!
Hyup.
YEAAH!
[Mousebro intensifies]
Why is he staring at meee?!
"3D obstacle course"
UAGH!
I didn't even get two steps...
Ha! HA! HAAAGH!
I made it! I made it! I made i--NOOO!
Bye son!
Have fun!
"I don't need my daddy to tell me what to do."
"He's such a douchebag!"
"He's always telling me what to d--"
"Oh-oh. AH! AAAARGH!"
[sounds of trying]
I didn't make it.
Huh, no! How gross!
BOOP!
Noo, that's disgusting!
I hate this, as I keep playing it.
Pleh. Ech. NO! NoO! Ech. NOoO! ECH!
There we go!
Got it! EUGH.
Oh my goodness!
This would be a magical adventure...
...if I wasn't humping this turtle.
Aaand I'm not moving, so...
...I guess, this is my life now.
[romantic music plays]
You stop that! It's unnatural!
Dhey, all right, you kiddies!
Let's make our country big on me!
WAAAH!
Come with me, my love!
We're going on a maghichal adventureh!
Filled with wonder and...BLEGH!
"Landmine run"
LANDMINE RUN?
Are kidding m-- oh goodness!
HOUAGH.
Hop... oh I'm now dead.
T-there's no question to it.
This is impossible!
Impossible!
Jumpjumpjump, flyflyfly!
FlyflyflyHEUGH!
UAGH!
COME ON!
HUAH-I'm okay, I'm okay. I'm gonna make it!
I'm gonna make it!
OOOH GOD! EWWW!
♫♪Iiiii don't wanna plaaaay this one!♫♪
Weee!
Okay, I need you guys to believe in me...
...because this is gonna be reallyAWGH!
WOOHOOHOO!
COME ON!
BELIEVE IN ME!
Land.
Keep going!
Son dead. Don't matter.
Still alive. Don't matter!
Still alive. DON'T MATTER!
YEAaAaAaH!
Okay-dokeyWOAH!
W-wh--this isn't right!
This doesn't feel natural!
This feels very wrooong!
AUGH-ahahah.
Up-up-up-up!
Up-up-AHH-up-up-up!
Gonna make it! Gonna make it!
I don't think I can make it!
I was lookin' at you...
...and not on the screen.
...when I should have been looking at... there.
I'm lookin' at you again!
I know you're all very beautiful...
...and lovely people...
...but I gotta concentrate on this!
I GOTTA WIN!
[pain noises]
This has been Happy Wheels Highligths.
Thanks for watching!
If you wanna see more Happy Wheels right now...
...check the description or click the annotation...
...for the full Happy Wheels playlist.
And if you wanna see more Happy Wheels in the future...
...please click the like button to let me know.
Thanks again everyone,...
...and, as always...
...I will see you...
...in the next video!
Bye-byeee!